Y para tomar nota de los países que han hecho un gran cambio:
[#ifAfricawasabar Ruanda sería esa chica
que viene sin dinero ni transporte, pero se va borracha, feliz y rica].
Pero lo más importante,
la gente estaba usando el hashtag para conectarse,
para conectarse a través de su africanidad.
Así que durante una semana en julio,
Twitter se convirtió en un auténtico bar africano.
Y yo estaba muy emocionada,
principalmente porque me di cuenta de que el panafricanismo podría funcionar,
que teníamos ante nosotros, entre nosotros, en nuestras manos,
una plataforma que solo necesitaba una pequeña chispa
para iluminar en nosotros un hambre por el otro.
Mi nombre es Siyanda Mohutsiwa,
tengo 22 años
y soy panafricana de nacimiento.
Digo que soy panafricanista de nacimiento
porque mis padres son de dos diferentes países africanos.
Mi padre de un país llamado Botswana en África meridional.
Es solo un poco más grande que Alemania.
Este año celebramos nuestro 50 años de democracia estable.
Y tiene algunas políticas sociales muy progresistas.
El país de mi madre es el Reino de Suazilandia.
Es un país pequeñísimo, también en el sur de África.
Es la última monarquía absoluta de África.
Ha sido gobernado por un rey y una familia real
de acuerdo con su tradición,
por un largo tiempo.
Sobre el papel, estos países parecen ser muy diferentes.
Y cuando era una niña, pude ver la diferencia.
Llovía mucho en un país, no llovía tanto en el otro.
Pero fuera de eso, realmente no me di cuenta
de la importancia de que mis padres fueran de dos lugares diferentes.
Lo cual tendría un efecto muy peculiar en mí.
Verán, yo nací en un país
y crecí en el otro.
Cuando nos mudamos a Botswana,
era una niña que hablaba suazi fluido
y nada más.
Así que fui introducida a mi nuevo hogar,
mi nueva identidad cultural,
como una completa extraña,
incapaz de comprender nada de lo que se me estaba diciendo
por la familia y el país cuyas tradiciones estaba destinada a seguir más adelante.
Pero muy pronto, olvidaría el suazi.
Y cuando regresé a Suazilandia,
era constantemente confrontada por lo no muy suazi en que me estaba convirtiendo.
A eso le sumanos mi entrada al sistema escolar privado de África,
cuya propósito último es eliminar la africanidad dentro de uno
y tendría una adolescencia muy peculiar.
Pero creo que mi interés en las ideas de identidad nació aquí,
en la extraña intersección de pertenecer a dos lugares a la vez
pero en realidad sin pertenecer a ninguno de los dos muy bien
y que pertenecer a este vasto espacio en medio y alrededor al mismo tiempo.
Me obsesioné con la idea de una identidad africana compartida.
Desde entonces, he seguido leyendo acerca de la política
y la geografía y la identidad y lo que significan todas esas cosas.
También me he aferrado a una profunda curiosidad por las filosofías africanas.
Cuando empecé a leer,
gravité hacia las obras de intelectuales negros
como Steve Biko y Frantz Fanon,
que abordaron ideas complejas
como la descolonización y la conciencia negro.
Y cuando pensaba que, a los 14 años, había digerido estas grandes ideas,
pasé a los discursos de los estadistas africanos icónicos
como de Burkina Faso, Thomas Sankara
y, de Congo, Patrice Lumumba.
Leí cada pieza de ficción africana que pude tener en mis manos.
Así que cuando llegó Twitter,
salté con el entusiasmo de una adolescente
cuyos amigos están de lo más aburridos de oír hablar de todas estas cosas.
Era el año 2011
y en todo el sur de África y en todo el continente,
se hizo mucho más fácil de conseguir, paquetes asequibles de datos
para teléfonos inteligentes y navegación por Internet.
Así que mi generación, estaba enviando mensajes entre sí en esta plataforma
que solo necesita 140 caracteres y un poco de creatividad.
En los largos viajes diarios al trabajo,
en las clases en las que algunos deberíamos haber prestando atención,
en nuestros almuerzos,
queríamos comunicar lo máximo posible
sobre las realidades cotidianas de ser joven y africano.
Pero, por supuesto, este lujo no estaba disponible para todo el mundo.
Así que esto significa que si uno era un adolescente en Botswana
y quería divertirse en Internet,
tenía que, uno, tuitear en Inglés.
Dos, tenías que seguir más de las otras tres personas que conociste en línea.
Había que seguir sudafricanos, zimbabuenses, ghaneses, nigerianos.
Y de repente, todo su mundo se abrió.
Y todo mi mundo sí que se abrió.
Seguí a los africanos vibrantes que viajaban por todo el continente,
tomando fotografías
y colocándolas bajo el hashtag #myafrica.
Debido a que en ese momento,
si buscaba África en Twitter o en Google
o cualquier tipo de medio,
se podría pensar que todo el continente era solo imágenes de animales
y chicos blancos bebiendo cócteles en complejos hoteleros.
(Risas)
Pero los africanos estaban usando esta plataforma
para tomar algún tipo de propiedad de los sectores de turismo.
Africanos tomando selfis en las playas de Nigeria.
Africanos en bares en Nairobi.
Y fueron estos mismos africanos los que empecé a conocer
en mis propios viajes por el continente.
Queríamos hablar de literatura africana, política, política económica.
Sin embargo, casi invariablemente en cada ocasión,
acabábamos discutiendo Twitter.
Y fue cuando me di cuenta de qué se trataba.
Estábamos parados en medio de algo sorprendente,
porque por primera vez en la historia
los jóvenes africanos podían discutir el futuro del continente en tiempo real,
sin la restricción de las fronteras, las finanzas y gobiernos vigilantes.
Por lo poco conocida que es la verdad
muchos africanos saben mucho menos sobre otros países africanos
que algunos occidentales saben sobre África en su conjunto.
Esto es por accidente,
pero a veces, es por diseño.
Por ejemplo, en el apartheid de Sudáfrica,
los sudafricanos negros fueron bombardeados constantemente
con el mensaje de que cualquier país gobernado por personas de raza negra
estaba destinado al fracaso.
Y esto se hizo para convencerlos
de que eran mucho mejor bajo el aplastante dominio blanco
de lo que estaban viviendo en una nación negra y libre.
Añadan al sistema colonial africano, el arcaico sistema de educación
que se ha arrastrado sin pensarlo desde la década de 1920...
a los 15 años, podía nombrar todas las diversas causas
de las guerras que habían sucedido en Europa en los últimos 200 años,
pero no podía nombrar al presidente de mi país vecino.
Y para mí, esto no tiene ningún sentido
porque nos guste o no,
los destinos de la gente de África están profundamente entrelazados.
Cuando ocurre un desastre, cuando la inestabilidad golpea,
compartimos las consecuencias.
Cuando huyen de Burundi por la agitación política,
vienen a nosotros,
a otros países africanos.
África tiene seis de los centros de refugiados más grandes del mundo.
Lo que antes era un problema de Burundi
se convierte en un problema africano.
Así que para mí, no hay problemas sudaneses
o problemas sudafricanos o problemas kenianos,
solo hay problemas africanos
porque, al final, compartimos la agitación.
Y si compartimos los problemas,
¿por qué no vamos a hacerlo mejor compartiendo los éxitos?
¿Cómo podemos hacer eso?
En el largo plazo,
podemos aumentar el comercio interafricano,
eliminar fronteras y presionar a los líderes
para que cumplan los acuerdos regionales que ya han firmado.
Pero creo que la forma más grande de África de compartir sus éxitos
es fomentar algo que me gusta llamar panafricanismo social.
Ahora, la política panafricanista ya existe,
así que no estoy inventando nada nuevo aquí.
Pero política panafricanismo
es por lo general la unidad africana de la élite política.
¿Y quiénes se benefician?
Bien, los líderes africanos, casi exclusivamente.
No, de lo que estoy hablando
es del panafricanismo del africano común.
Jóvenes africanos como yo,
llenos de energía creativa,
con ideas innovadoras.
Sin embargo, con las malas y temblorosas instituciones de gobierno,
todo este potencial se podría perder.
En un continente donde poco más de un puñado de líderes
han estado en el poder más
que la mayoría de las poblaciones que han vivido,
tenemos la necesidad desesperada de algo nuevo,
algo que funcione.
Y creo que eso es el panafricanismo social.
Mi sueño es que los jóvenes africanos
dejen de permitir que las fronteras y las circunstancias sofoquen la innovación.
Mi sueño es que cuando un joven africano venga con algo brillante,
no le digan: "Bueno, esto no funcionaría en mi país",
y luego se rindan.
Mi sueño es que los jóvenes africanos empiecen a darse cuenta
de que todo el continente es nuestro lienzo, es nuestro hogar.
Con Internet, podemos empezar a pensar de forma colaborativa,
podemos empezar a innovar juntos.
En África, se dice: "Si quieres ir rápido, ve solo,
pero si quieres llegar lejos, ve acompañado".
Y creo que el panafricanismo social es como podemos ir muy lejos juntos.
Y esto ya está sucediendo.
El acceso a estas redes en línea ha dado a los jóvenes africanos
algo que siempre hemos tenido que tomar con violencia: una voz.
Ahora tenemos una plataforma.
Antes, si uno quería saber de los jóvenes en África,
esperaba a que el ministro de la juventud, de 65 años de edad,
(Risas)
se despertara en la mañana,
tomara su medicación para la gastritis
y después les dijera los planes que tenía para su generación
dentro de 20 años.
Antes, si querías ser escuchados por su posiblemente tiránico gobierno,
eran empujados a protestar, sufrir las consecuencias
y tener los dedos cruzados
para que un medio occidental les pusiera atención.
Pero ahora tenemos la oportunidad de respaldarnos el uno al otro
en formas en las que nunca antes se pudo.
Apoyamos a los estudiantes de Sudáfrica
que protestan contra las ridículamente altas tarifas terciarias.
Apoyamos a las mujeres de Zimbabwe que están marchando al parlamento.
Apoyamos a los periodistas angoleños que son detenidos ilegalmente.
Por primera vez,
el dolor de África y la aspiración de África
tiene la capacidad de ser vistos
por aquellos que pueden identificarse más con ellas:
otros africanos.
Creo que con un pensamiento panafricanista social
y usando Internet como una herramienta,
podemos empezar a rescatar a unos de otros,
y en última instancia, rescatarnos a nosotros mismos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)